I agree with you that faith is
definitely essential to establish human
rights on an individual level because
that is what is going to motivate you
but I think that one of the primary
problems that we're seeing in the world
today is that faith is not a generic
term faith is very specific and so when
you use the word faith it means
different things to different people
when you if you're coming for example
from Christian tradition generally faith
is not attached to a specific legal code
whereas when you're talking to a Muslim
then there would be attached in a very
complex legal code and so it's easier
for a person coming from a Christian
tradition to agree to a generic even for
to a certain degree secular standard of
human rights because from his tradition
there is no specific religious standard
is very generic I'm being relatively
obviously whereas for coming from a
Muslim tradition and probably in from a
Jewish tradition you would have a far
more legalistic far more specific value
system and so I think the clash would
come not faith faithful versus faithless
but rather from within the faith
traditions themselves so it's just like
a comment to me a good it's a good
comment and i would say briefly in
response concurring in your comment but
human rights formulations in many ways
provide mirrors in which religious
communities can reflect upon their own
normative traditions their own canonical
formulations of what the good life in
the good society happened to be and to
articulate in their own terms what views
what values what practices what
institutional structures are consonant
with sometimes go beyond the human
rights values articulated in these
universal declarations and many times
what happens is when give the 48
declaration or the 66 covenant or other
formulations like that are used as a way
of thinking about how do we in our
millennium long tradition think about
these goods there's a lot of overlap my
colleague of Diwaniyah Nayeem is a
scholar who's been working out of the
Sufi tradition he's a victim of
ostracism without trial from his own
native Sudan he knows what it means to
be a victim of human rights abuses but
what he has spent his life
what I'm doing is to look at the Quran
and the hadith and some of the schools
of jurisprudence before the closing of
the door and and to think hard through
what those particular canonical texts
and initial jurisprudential reflections
offer to the 20th and 21st century for
Muslims and non-muslims alike about
human rights now sometimes the terms
don't match many times the practices
don't match but nonetheless what he
argues is that there is an awful lot of
overlap between some of the great
teachings of the Prophet some of the
injunctions of hadith and some of what
we now take to be human rights claims
Muslim communities are doing that in
different parts of the non-arabic muslim
world jewish communities are doing that
looking back at the hebrew bible and
Talmudic exegesis of the same Hindu
scholars Buddhist scholars Confucian
scholars Taoist scholars alike are doing
that and inevitably inevitably you need
a big rosetta stone with seven or eight
what the lines of text running at the
same time to keep the languages straight
inevitably you have to recognize they're
going to be sharp differences I propose
the question of Rachel that there may be
sharp differences in which there is no
overlapping consensus but it's
remarkable how many basic values the
life the property to maintenance of
one's name to the ability to get married
to the care of one's child to the basic
security one's home that these religious
communities paint for granted as part of
the original canonical formulations even
if they embroider them in a variety of
different ways in that sense I think you
know human rights today are very useful
ingredients for thinking about common
values together knowing that they're not
the only formulation they're by no means
the superior formulation but there
nonetheless a useful grid for thinking
about what we hold together and how we
can formulate relationships together
that are politically and culturally and
socially cogent